voilà on va voir un peu de plus près ce
qui s'est produit comment ça s'est
produit dans l'espace parce que s'il ya
rien de tel qu'un avant et après pour se
faire une tête sur ce qui s'est produit
à voir cette plus près d'abord l'élément
central dans tout ça derrière moi c'est
là la voie ferrée elle même qui on le
voit ici qu'on tourne en quelque sorte
ce qui est une partie du centre
patrimonial de patrimonia louis de lac
mégantic
alors c'est à cet endroit là que les
trains régulièrement passer le point le
centre névralgique là où ces produits
donc l'explosion et tout ce qui s'en est
suivi c'est exactement très exactement
ici et on voit tout près donc ça c'est
la rue frontenac une des rues centrales
principal de se trouver des lieux
importants pour les gens dans leur
quotidien
ici tout juste ici c'est le music a fait
c'est à cet endroit que se trouver en ce
vendredi d'une paisible soirée d'été des
dizaines et des dizaines de personnes
des jeunes pour la plupart du temps je
souligne qu'ils étaient donc là tout
près l'explosion je vous laisse présumer
du reste alors voilà pour pour le reste
de ce qu'on voit ici avant que tout
bascule
il ya la bibliothèque et les archives
donc municipal une perte totale un peu
plus loin un dollar à main fraîchement
rénové perte totale une pharmacie jean
coutu
heureusement épargné donc par les
flammes et tout le reste reste que le
sous sol est complètement inondé va
falloir déplacer tout ça pour rendre ce
service aux gens et de l'autre côté des
commerces ici j'attire votre attention
sur une zone résidentielle où
présumément cette heure-là se trouvaient
des gens qui dormaient paisiblement
on passe maintenant à la suite des
choses c'est-à-dire lé après on va voir
ce qu'il en reste la perspective change
un peu suivez moi vous allez comprendre
donc toujours cette voie ferrée est ici
est donc l amoncellement de wagons
citernes et qui ont pris feu et voilà
tout ce qui reste finalement le music a
fait remarquer la distance
la très très courte distance entre le
lieu de l'explosion et le music a fait
où se trouve une bonne partie des
victimes présumées et voilà tout le
reste
la bibliothèque municipale l'aide de la
ram 1 et la zone résidentielle
rapidement je passe une dernière image
aérienne celle ci pour que vous
compreniez est un autre aspect des
choses
voici la polyvalente montignac où se
trouve un bon nombre donc des sinistrés
et d'où nous parlent certains de nos
journalistes et un peu plus loin et
c'est à dire ici
le lieu de l'impact c'est 2,5 km qui ne
l'est pas à ces deux endroits là le lac
donc mégantic et ici la rivière
chaudière qui s'y déversent
et là je mentionne ces deux points d'eau
évidemment cause des risques
environnementaux potentiels
alors voilà un portrait global mais
partielle aussi de la situation
pour vous situer un peu plus un peu plus
sur comment ça s'est passé
où ça s'est passé sur cette tragédie
terrible tragédie